Hey, everyone.
What's up?
It's Rob Dodson.
Today on Polycast
I'm going to take you
down the path of creating a
public API for your elements.
We're also going to be answering
questions from the audience,
so be sure to stick
around for that.
First, let's hop into some code.
So the first part of creating
a public API for your element
is declaring public
properties, and this
has changed a bunch from Polymer
0.5 to the newest version.
In previous versions
of Polymer, if you
wanted to declare public
properties for your element
there was an attributes
attribute that you
could put properties in.
There was a
published object then
you could put properties in,
and sometimes it was confusing.
You know, where should
you put your stuff?
So in the latest
version of Polymer,
this has all been consolidated
into one single properties
object, and it's a
very powerful object.
So let me show it to
you, and we can check out
some of the cool
things that it does.
So first and foremost, I've
got an x-custom element
that I've created here, I've
got a properties object,
and I've got two
properties, first and last,
and I've set string
to their values.
Which basically tells Polymer
that when someone passes
in a value for first and
last, that value should
be de-serialized to a string.
So that's really nice.
You can de-serialize
to various other types,
like number, object, et cetera.
Another cool thing
that you can do
is you can pass in a default
value for a property.
So I've got an
age property here,
I've set its type to number,
and a default value of 42.
You can also create observers
for your properties.
So these are functions
that will run
whenever the property changes.
So here I've set observer to
this age changed function.
And in previous
versions of Polymer,
we had this notion of changed
watchers, which were functions
that we kind of secretly
implemented for you.
If you had a public
property, you've
got one of those
functions for free.
It was a little bit of magic.
Now that has been
sort of removed,
and if you want to
observe a changing
need to explicitly create
an observer like this.
Which is nice.
It sort of-- if someone
was looking at your code
and they weren't
quite sure where
that function was
coming from, this
clears up any confusion there.
And one thing to point
out is that because this
is effectively like
a private function,
I don't want a bunch of
people calling this method,
I would only like it to
run if my property changes,
I'm prefixing it
with an underscore.
And that's something that we're
doing with all the Polymer
elements just to highlight
to folks that this
is internal to the element and
not meant to the outside world
to call.
And other thing
that you can do is
you can have your element
dispatch change events anytime
its property is updated.
So this is similar to the way
that native Dom elements work.
You've got input, and
select, and, you know,
when they change they actually
fire events every single time
to notify folks.
So adding a notify
property to your element
is going to dispatch those
change events for you.
So I'll get an
age changed event.
And the nice thing
is this is actually
the basis for the two way
binding system in Polymer.
So if you want one of these
properties here to a bindable,
you need to make
sure that you've
got notify true set on it.
Also, hopefully,
this makes it easier
to interop with
other frameworks.
So there are other
frameworks out there
that have their own
data binding systems,
and previously it
was unclear how
they could know at what point
in a Polymer elements life
to actually check for changes.
This way it's
getting an event, it
can listen for that
it's consistent,
and that way we can, hopefully,
interop with some other data
binding systems.
Now, another really
awesome that you can do
is create computer properties.
So let's say I want
to take first and last
and combine them
together into one value.
I can do that here by passing
a computed key, and then
a compute full
name function name,
and I'm passing in
the two properties
that I would like to
send in as arguments.
So I'm passing in
first and last.
Now, it's important to
include these arguments here,
because what they do
is they tell Polymer
that any time first or last
changes this compute full name
function should run again
to update this value.
So very, very
useful trick there.
Another thing that you can do
is create read only properties.
So let's say you have an element
with some internal state,
you don't want the outside
world playing around with it,
you can set that
property to read
only so that way folks
can only get the value,
they can never set it.
Lastly, one thing
that's really cool
is you can reflect values back
to attributes if you need to.
So this is really
helpful if someone
is trying to style your
element with the CSS attribute
selector.
You probably won't use
this guy that much,
but it's there if you need it.
For the new properties
object gives you
a kind of power, let's
hop into the Code Editor
and actually put
this into practice.
So I'm going to start, as
I do with all my elements,
in a Bower JSON file.
I've got an element that
I've created called name tag,
and in my dependencies I've
listed Polymer 0.9.0-rc.1.
So this is the release
candidate for rc.1,
which is what's currently
available at the time
of this recording.
But if you're watching this
and, I'm assuming by now
the 0.9.0 tag is actually
out-- so you can actually
take this value
here and probably
just go ahead and replace
it in your Bower JSON
with a little caret 0.9.0.
And that should get you
the latest tag of Polymer.
Now over in my
terminal, I'm going
to run Bower install to pull
down that version of Polymer,
and then back in
Sublime I can create
a name dash tag HTML file.
And this is where I'm going
to put my elements definition.
The first thing I've
got to do, as always,
is use the canonical
path to import Polymer.
Then I'm going to
create a Dom module was
an ID that matches my elements
tag name, so ID of name tag,
and inside of there I
will throw a template
and that's where I'm going
to put all of the local Dom
content for my element.
The next thing I need to do is
call the Polymer constructor,
and I need to give
it an is property
and pass in my tag name.
And then I'm also going to
create a properties object
for it, and I will create
first and last properties
and I'm going to set
those to strings.
Then I will create a div
up here called full name,
and I will bind those values
up to spans inside of that div.
Now in previous
versions of Polymer,
you could actually create
these binding expressions
where you have multiple
values and multiple bindings
all kind of mushed into one tag.
Currently in
Polymer, that is not
supported though it
is on the roadmap.
So if you need to get both
first and last into this div,
you've got to wrap them
inside of spans which
is a little funky and
we're going to come back
to this point in a moment.
But so far, just
with this right here,
we're ready to
preview our element.
So I'll go to my
index file, and I'm
going to import definition
for my name tag element.
And then down in the body,
I can drop in a name tag
and I can configure it
with first and last value.
So I'm just going to pass
in my name as those values.
Next, I'm going to run the
trustee polyserve module
to actually preview my element.
Polyserve is a little
local node server
that you can use to
test out your component,
it plays very nicely with Bower.
If you have no idea
what I'm talking about,
you can check out this
video her right here.
We've got a full episode
which explains how to get up
and running with polyserve.
If you are building
a lot of elements,
this is an invaluable tool.
So it is worth your time
to check out that episode.
Now, over in Chrome, I'm
going to refresh the page
and you can see over
here-- I'll kind of
boost this up a
little bit for you--
that my name is now showing up.
So I've got first and
last, those binding values
are being displayed there.
It's a little boring, right?
But at least you
can see it works.
And back in my
element definition,
I'm going to try to
clean this up a little
bit because having
those spans there
is little bit of a funky
hack, and to do that I'm going
to use a computed property.
So in my properties object,
I will create a full name
property.
I'm going to say it's
computed, and then it
computes first and last.
And then down here, I can
actually implement that method.
So it takes first and
last as arguments,
it returns a string that
is the concatenated values.
Then up in my div,
I can just drop
in a binding for full name.
Now the next thing
I want to do to make
this tag look a little
bit nicer is actually add
some styles in here.
So I'm styling the host, and
I'm styling that full name div.
And what this is
going to give me,
when I go back to Chrome
and refresh the page,
is something that looks a little
bit more like a name badge.
And you can see that I
still see my full name their
using that computer property.
OK, I'm going to clue you
in on a little pro tip now.
If you'd like to declare your
computer properties in line
you can totally do that,
and that's really useful
if you want to have a
computer property maybe only
in one place.
It'll keep your properties
object nice and tidy, so
let me show you how to do that.
So to declare a computed
property in the line,
we can actually delete
this full name property
that we've got here.
And then up in our
binding we can just
call compute full name, pass
in first and last properties,
and then that's going to call
this guy and return a value.
So going back to Chrome,
refresh the page,
I see the exact same thing, but
I've tidied up my properties
object a little bit.
And this, again, is helpful if
you have a property that maybe
you're only using in one place.
Now one last thing
I want to show you
is how to add a public
method to your component.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to add like a shake method
so that the name tag actually
wiggles around a little bit.
So to do that I'm going to start
off with a little bit of CSS,
and notice this host selector
that I've written here.
So I'm targeting the
host and then I've
got these parentheses, and
I'm passing in a class name.
And what that does is
it allows the element
to reference itself.
It's basically saying
if I have a class called
shake applied to me, then
use all of these styles.
I'm just creating
an animation here.
What I'm going to do is
drop in some key frames,
and these key frames
just have the element
go to the right a little,
to the left a little,
and then back to the center.
And I've got the vendor prefixed
versions of this key frames
as well, so, you
know, moz key frame,
webkit key frame, et cetera.
So it looks like a lot more
code than it really is.
Now I'm going to go
down to my prototype,
and I can actually
implement a shake method.
So all I'm doing is I'm saying
this this.classlist.toggle that
shake class.
So you're going to
add it, the element
is going to shake
around, you're going
to toggle it so it'll
removed, called again,
the element shakes
around, et cetera.
So we hop over to Chrome, and
I can pop up in the dev tools
and use this little
inspector here
to select my element
in the document.
And you can see that I've
got highlighted there,
and I can hit Escape
to open up my console,
and I'll show you a neat trick
if you haven't seen it before.
When you're in the
console and you've
got an element
selected up there,
you can hit $0 to actually
select that element.
It's like calling
query selector.
So now I can just say $0,
call that shake public method,
and you'll see it shaking.
I can call it again,
and you'll see
that that class that we added
gets removed because we're
calling classless toggle.
Called again, it shakes.
Call again, class gets removed.
So on and so on.
So a bit of a quick
and dirty example,
but now you know how to
add public properties
and public methods
to your element.
So there you have it.
You now know how to create the
public API for your element.
Now don't run away
just yet, stick around
because in Q&A time,
we're going to be
answering questions
in the audience
and giving away some swag.
Be sure to click that
little subscribe button.
As always, thank you
so much for watching,
and I'll see you next time.
All right, folks.
Q&A time.
Today's question comes from
Kash Cummings who asks,
you've mentioned
using the [INAUDIBLE]
before to style elements can
be dangerous because it can
cause unintended side effects.
Is there a more
general way to style
elements that doesn't
require knowing
all about their internals?
It's a really great
question, Kash, thanks
for sending that in.
This is actually one of the
cooler features of the latest
version of Polymer.
We've got a brand
new styling system,
it's still experimental
but has shipped.
You can follow this link right
here to read more about it.
It is based on CSS variables
and custom properties.
And I personally
think it's so cool.
The next episode of
Polycast is actually
going to be all about it,
so stay tuned for that.
Again, thank you Kash for
sending in your question.
To all of you out there,
please send more questions
down in the comments.
We'll send you some swag
if you get featured.
As always, thanks for watching.
I'll see you next time.